welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid I seem to remember someone asking
for an antimatter video like a year ago
huh that was a long time ago so what
makes animators so special anyway I
don't know let's ask anti Nick why do I
look like this because you're made of
antimatter you do realize that
antimatter doesn't look any different
than normal matter right your atoms are
made of protons neutrons and electrons
mine are made of anti protons
antineutrons and anti electrons or
positrons but they both behave the same
way and they both emit the same kinds of
light so it's actually very difficult to
tell a normal atom apart from an anti
atom so what look like this hey you're
the guy I normally work with yep no
wonder you never touch me okay
calling it antimatter makes it sound
like some exotic kind of matter but it
really isn't of course then you might be
wondering why can't I touch him because
we didn't aisle eight each other but
what exactly does that mean and why does
it happen to understand this we need to
accept something else there are a lot of
particles I mean look at this list of
baryons in this list of missins how many
ways they interact would be an even
bigger list but there are some rules
that need to be followed
they're called conservation laws and
they're really important anyway let's
look at some examples when an electron
comes close to another electron they
push each other away because like
charges repel and that's not very
exciting if an electron and a proton
come close then they'll be drawn
together because opposites attract but
they'll just form a hydrogen atom which
isn't very exciting either sticking with
opposites though an electron has a
negative one charge and an up quark has
a positive two-thirds charge if they
come together they'll actually cease to
exist and make two new particles a Down
quark and a neutrino and they're not
even anti particles so what happens if
two anti particles like an electron and
a positron come together they cease to
exist
too but since their charges are
perfectly opposite negative 1 and
positive 1 they have to make something
neutral and the easiest neutral thing to
make is a photon the particle of light
that's all antimatter really is their
opposite properties cancel each other in
the interaction which leaves you with a
whole lot of zero values it's mostly
just the coincidence I mean some
particles are their own antiparticles
like the humans we are we impose our
preconceived notions on it so wait why
aren't all people made of antimatter
me yeah I guess that's kind of weird
isn't it so I guess there's one thing
that makes antimatter special there
isn't that much of it and whenever we
make it it doesn't last very long
because it finds a partner and makes a
photon so why isn't the universe made
entirely of photons way back at the
beginning the universe was chock-full of
photons those photons occasionally made
quark anti quark pairs but like usual
they didn't last very long before
recombining eventually things cooled off
enough for those pairs to separate and
combine in other ways to form things
like protons and antiprotons but that
should have made an equal number of each
and they should have all annihilated by
now so what gives well we're not sure
but we're hoping the Large Hadron
Collider will answer it for us and we do
have a few ideas some think the early
universe might have allowed conservation
law violations which makes me
uncomfortable others think that
antimatter might decay faster than
normal matter but then we're making it
sound special again the one I like the
best there's still an equal amount of
matter in antimatter
but the super fast expansion of the
early universe separated it that means
some of the galaxies we see out there
could actually be made entirely of
antimatter how cool is that so do you
think there are any antimatter galaxies
out there let us know in the comments if
you want to learn more about what
antimatter is and how we discovered it
you should go over to the super enzyme
justice league and check out their video
I hosted it they also helped out with
the graphics in this video don't forget
to subscribe if you'd like to see more
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy